so which one is it which one is it okay
the first thing I'm going to do
sorry okay the first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to rule out a quarter
here's how here's why okay remember this
probably tree is all labeled all over
like it's particularly its labeled with
these fractions why did I bother doing
that so I know the probability of each
event and specifically like the reason
it's important to know that it's because
they're not the same
do you agree right this event is less
likely than this one so had i drawn the
diagram like this i would be implying
everything has the same chance okay
everything's equal waiting I guess that
would make it 5050 1/2 1/2 but that's
not the case it's not true okay so each
time you consider one of the little
components one of the stages of the
event they all weighted differently is
the way that I would say it okay it's a
little bit obvious if you think about
like rolling a six and not roaring six
well clearly one is much less likely
than the other so you're going to get
different probabilities all the way
through so even though there are four
possibilities it's not simply one out of
four I've got to think about something a
little more specific so these numbers
are going to come into play these guys
here in fact we may like to circle them
[Applause]
this will do so yes we have some come to
this this guy in this guy so my question
then is do I add these or do I multiply
them oops now so I've heard the
suggestion when I put I keep on putting
things down sorry this is not the one I
want this is a dud did anyone see did I
put it down comic desk will just drop it
somewhere our tiring area I do need to
add some times and I do need to multiply
some times so my question is which one
and why hmm
now some of you said to me multiply if
you've said that my question is for what
reason why multiply it and not add yeah
okay so what Eliana's said is exactly
right I'll come back to it in a moment
in more detail what in case you didn't
hear was as I go down if I'm considering
like different things together I add if
I go across I multiply now that's
exactly true but it doesn't tell me why
that's true and the reason why I don't
like that is because in an exam under
pressure I'm just as likely to remember
it the other way around
because no clear reason is to it this or
the other ones good random to be honest
let me try and explain okay let's think
about something simpler let's think
about something simpler so what's hard
about this is that it's a complicated
situation so if I give you a simpler
situation okay heads or tails
it's heads I'm going to go again heads
or tails pan heads again okay now I just
flipped two heads in a row what's the
probability of flipping two heads in a
row what's the probability of flipping a
head just just 1/2 50% right that was
the first time about the second time now
just like here I've got a multi-stage
event July and or do I multiply what
would happen if I added 1/2 plus 1/2 is
1 what does that mean in probability
terms that means it's going to happen
guaranteed right thanks all good and ha
ok
a shorter actually they're also really
smart but there's a shot at um this
doesn't this doesn't seem right does it
right what this is saying is oh there's
a 100% chance that you'll flip two heads
in a row I mean times am I going to have
two foot to prove this wrong heads
that's embarrassing isn't it that's bad
tail double your fun okay so if
thankfully through experimentation we
can prove it's not a 100 percent chance
you're going to get two heads in a row
in fact it's a 25 percent chance does
that make sense does that make sense
right it's a quarter so what are we
going to do as a conclusion right to
work out the probability of getting
incompetent number twice in a row I'm
going to multiply across this is the
reason why it's multiplying across and
adding down because if you did it any
other way you would get crazy things
right where it's like the more times you
do something the more likely it becomes
what about three years in a row if you
were adding then it's like oh yeah this
is 150 percent likely okay so that's
bogus okay that's going to be a night
I'm going to be a bit rude and put equal
sides across the page because I've run
out of space what's it probably of this
club to sit there not a cup sir have a
look have a look it's different isn't it
1/3 times 2/3 2 over 9 what about this
one
look look at them across yeah that's
kind of important it means something
different that's going to overnight
again and the very last one that's
foreign-owned isn't it now remember I
said to you before if you look at any
individual level so yeah a little bit
she is a level here one of the
probabilities add up to one
what are these one each each part as
it's one right and that's a really
important thing to look for one of the
way that you know that you've done this
final step right is that it's still true
one nine two notes two notes four notes
it still adds up to one does that make
sense so this is actually a really
important way that you can know that you
have done it right